foreign
all right
we live we're doing it
we're doing hot breath averse welcome
back to hot breath live this is our
weekly live stream we do every Tuesday
on our YouTube channel we bring on some
of the games most influential people so
you can ask you their questions wait you
ask them ask your questions directly
it's that Sugar I can just sorry I'm uh
I'm having sugar withdrawals and I'm
just excited about today's guest because
in this show and us doing over 400
interviews with comedians primarily
we've interviewed several successful
quote social media comedians but haven't
really gotten the people behind the
person and this guy
started in TV developing shows
transitioned to social media and has
literally like changed the game has a
big thumb print on why we do what we do
and why social media is the most really
important way to build a following
yeah in a fan base to sell tickets this
guy's gonna tell us how we did it so we
can do it
hopefully
yeah I'm super excited man this is this
is one of those things that you're
always been curious about you're like
all right how how did all that happen
with that and now we get to get deep and
dive in I'm looking forward to this one
so let's delay no longer my friends this
guy has a roster
of comedians with millions of followers
so you're going to want to take notes
you're going to want to reach out to him
after this and you're going to want to
join our email list because we'll be
sharing a breakdown of what we learned
here afterwards so get that Linked In
the description of this episode and
without further Ado please welcome to
the hot breath verse the one the only
the John Edmonds cozum cosma everyone
you got me nervous here John you got me
nervous here oh what's going on man John
you do have a name of like a UFC fighter
[Laughter]
that's my
Brazil fighting jiu jitsu
well I had to keep the full name because
I don't know if I think when I first
started doing something I think the full
name got out there and I thought about
it and I said if somebody's going to
search me I'll probably more
found if it's a full name with Edmonds
in the middle because there might be
several giant Cosmos so I just went with
the full name from a a CEO standpoint
oh is it cosma Cosmo oh I I researched
this in an interview you did someone
called you cosma and I just assumed that
was right and I dang it oh no worries no
worries how embarrassing
where are you from John where are you
from originally I'm from North Carolina
born in Asheville yeah all right all the
way from Asheville North Carolina
what'd you say I'm sorry I live in
Charleston South Carolina now
Charleston okay all the way from
Charleston South Carolina re-entry to Mr
John edsman cosma did I get it cosma
cosma Mr John we're over two John is not
gonna help us go viral now he is like
I'm just looking at us who's like yeah I
think these guys are gonna screw it up
once more well let's just get into the
juice here John so if you could just
give give the high pressure a brief
background on what you have built with
bang Productions and what what you're
doing here just to give them some
context for like what we're about to get
into today man
well we we took a guide from the trailer
from the Talladega National Forest uh
living on his dad's property to just for
laughs and and two years and doubled
down on that blueprint and now we're one
of 30 companies in the world it's a meta
media partner
uh and just recently approached by Tick
Tock to be uh one of the first major U.S
agencies for tick tock we'll see if that
finalizes but uh
yeah and and I never knew I had
intelligence I never knew I had
intelligence in Tech until I started
talking to people in Tech
because a lot of people in entertainment
didn't really understand what I did
what is what is let's let's let's get
into this blueprint man let's get in
here
um what is uh maybe we start with what
are mistakes you're seeing most
comedians make on social media
well they need to quit listening to
everybody
you know is the first thing you know
because I think comedians in a way you
get a bunch of them in a room and every
one of them's got a different idea on
what they should do for their career and
I think you need to look within yourself
and find yourself and find some firm
footing for yourself and understand who
you are
and then project that to the world you
know I think I think you're only you
know
you're only strong I'll say if you come
from a Pure Source of Who You Are
how does that make sense how do you how
do you discover your pure self well if
you're if you have 10 different ideas
that are being told to you in your ear
or whatever and you're a highly
sensitive individual which most
comedians are you know it makes your
thought process go so many different
directions you forget
what you you know what's coming from the
heart you know and I think if you got a
narrative to put out to the world you
and these come from the heart and if and
if it's deluded in any way it you're not
going to be as good as you can be
so if a comedian is listening oh I'm
tracking John don't you worry yeah we're
with you here buddy yeah so if a
comedian is listening to this and
they're like I want to make my big push
on social media I want to be like just
the community you're talking about is
Southern mama who you took from the
trailer to Just for Laughs in two years
so if it means like I want to do that or
I at least want to get going and get
momentum on social media start building
my following where should they start
well when I looked at
the comedy industry and if you think
about the trajectory and what industry
would tell comedians to do they said hey
you need to start digging
right and if you think about it you
let's say you do you know five to seven
shows a week and you're starting out and
say 50 people come to a show they have
no idea who they're coming to see
all right and then
you start that process and let's say
that let's say you pull two or three
people out of that show that can relate
to your tone people will relate to your
tone based on law of attraction
so if you pull two people out of each
show based on your tone that resonates
with with the uh people watching the
show think about the growth that's why
it takes people in comedy 10 12 years
two
get to where they need to get to because
because
in saying that I realized that people in
in comedy were trying to appease
the industry they weren't thinking about
who's paying the bills
yo
big facts yeah that's big yeah yeah like
I want to throw up a fire emoji and a
hundred uh fire emerge yeah 100 fire
Emoji 100. yeah because industry forgot
who's paying
for sure so like when you think about
like
the way you sort of your example and how
you built up Southern mama what was the
thing that you saw that you were like
okay we're gonna start this differently
and this is how we're gonna start it
oh most people from a producing
standpoint
when I looked at it you know I thought
about focused energy you know how do we
create focused energy and and then I
looked at how
I think Darren had about 200 000 fans
when we started uh on Facebook
and I just looked at the response of the
people how they were responding
you know they're saying here's you know
their spirit animal these females spirit
animal and they're you know they loved
him and just he his relatability was off
the charts
so when I looked at that I was like from
a producing standpoint I didn't want to
dilute his narrative
so basically all I did was I think I
think he had 15 minutes set you know to
start with 15 minutes of material I said
let me just let me just create an
outline and help him with his timing
structurally and and him fill the holes
with the content because I think the
more authentic you are
uh going back to your Pure Source and
what comes from the heart more authentic
it's more relatable to the masses and I
think that was forgotten in comedy
does that make sense
yeah I love that your truest authentic
self is actually what's the most
relatable
yeah I mean it's like I mean if you if
you have a narrative it's very very
relatable that's coming from the heart
stay with that narrative don't don't
listen to anybody else you know stay
with that narrative because it will be
more relatable to the masses as you grow
your career
you know and then you can build whatever
narrative you want to offer that
relatability but I think a true artist
has to be contemporary to themselves
you know based on their age based on
their environment you know and and
that's a big deal I think you're it
keeps you as a true artist in a way so
if you have that understanding and that
mindset
and then you understand social media and
you put that out to the world
uh you're going to have a better
reaction
because it's it's going to be more
relatable and and the quicker you build
you'll be able to build quicker with
better relatability and and Darren the
the thing that Darren's trajectory was
so
uh fast is he had a 90 female fan base
and I discovered that the number one
Avatar was a 32 year old female that
made uh forty to sixty thousand dollars
a year
sting and that was just from your own
research to get to that in terms of just
looking at the I guess
I knew I didn't want to like I mean we
sold out 150 shows in a row when we
started but I I knew that
you know I didn't want to take the
normal industry standard route I said if
we can find a balance of creating
content
and building a Pure Source of fans right
we'll double down on on his relatability
and brought in a Pure Source of fans and
then sell back to that source
right it was a stronger deal
um and a lot of people in common May
disagree with that they're like well
they're coming to see you know
uh it's not Universal it's not this
but one does it have to be Universal if
I can sell tickets to a Pure Source they
already know who they're coming to see
the defense mechanism is already done
you know and double down on that process
so what would you let's let's say me for
example
I'm I'm married I have a dog I like
gardening I like pins I mean I've tried
to create content around all these
different things like what what would
you looking at me and how I sh like you
look at me and you're like wow this guy
should be more famous like you know this
guy this guy's got all the goods
and then what what would you what would
you do how would you mold me into Fame
so my wife doesn't make me get a real
job what would you do John all right
let's let's figure out your micro
moments of the day let's break down your
life in real real time
so when you get out of bed from say 8
A.M
to noon
what do you do that's real
I meditate
I exercise
I walk with my wife every morning we go
on a walk with our dog
I write in the mornings
will typically shower
um
when you meditate and exercise you ever
get interrupted by your kids does
somewhat anything you know out of those
scenarios or anything oddly
that happens
um I don't have kids I have a dog
so if anything odd happens
um well when we go on a walk we
definitely like to avoid people even
though we live in a neighborhood we do
try to we'll turn around sometimes if we
see people
um
I noticed
if I wave at people I notice when they
don't wave back
um
anything else odd
um I love cereal
I'm addicted to sugar
um there you go there's there's bits
right there I think if you break down
micro moments of your life
you know how do you wrap around
relatable tags to who you are
how many you know how many single
guys out there kind of Norm family
family-ish type of guy
you know what tags and and funny things
can you create about your real life and
who you are
because I think it once you once you
figure that out then you project
because it's so it's so close to you
then you project differently
right you know you start getting that
rhythm of understanding Who You Are
creating a tag creating a a set around
that
I think that's how you start and just
and go from there
it's so funny that you mentioned sort of
the
like the Persona and finding yourself
because we hear in comedy right because
I'm I'm we we hear this thing that it
takes you like 10 years to find yourself
in comedy
and what I'm hearing you say is if you
can find yourself much sooner you can
change the game for yourself by being
much more pure and much more authentic
to yourself because it feels like that
is what's sort of happening with comedy
is that authenticity is much more
uh is being much more rewarded because
that's what people are relating to to
your point absolutely so how would you
help comedians get to more authentic
well I'm just you just got to look at
your own life and you know like if Joel
shows up you know hadn't had kids yet
I'm sure his parents got a lot to say
about that
you know what I mean right you know like
stuff like that you know because because
like I said I think it's like a a factor
right you find these micro moments of
your own life and then if when you're
trying to tell that story it's a
stronger position it's a stronger voice
you're coming to instead of
you know trying to pull in elements of
things you think are funny uh as a
one-liner I mean I know a lot of you
know when comedy started Saturday Night
Live and I entered and viewed Alan's
wabel you know comedy was about
one-liners back then
but I think things have changed because
you know everything is an identity world
so I think you have to create that
identity on who you truly are and that's
what people gravitate to it's just it's
just like you know it's just like these
these networks I said you should reverse
engineer how Netflix you know sells
their shows like it's all right when
they Market a show it's Netflix name of
the show then who's starring in the show
you've already lost from a standpoint of
that structure you've already lost 20 to
30 percent of your potential audience
because they're not going to pay
attention by the time you get to the
third of who's starring in the show
instead of saying Kevin Hart stars in
this show here's the name of the show
and here's the network because nobody
really gives a [__] who the network is
but if they know there's an identity up
front that they like they'll go find
that an identity anywhere
does that make sense
it's an identity world
and people want to follow identities
that they can relate to
yeah I like that so as you sort of
I I love the way that your mind works in
terms of like reverse engineering sort
of it's almost like you're reverse
engineering the game but you're also
reverse engineering what everyone has
been told about comedy for the last like
a couple of decades and how to get there
and how to you know what I mean like I'm
not gonna lie we're all you know we're
all we kind of also do the same thing in
the sense of like man you got to get
those reps in man you got to go gigging
you got to get on stage you gotta be
funner you gotta do the 10 years sort of
commitment of just grind grind grind
grind grind grind grind and what you're
saying is
find you first it's almost like find who
you are like quickly
and almost find your fan base and almost
like feed that fan base is that is that
a good way of describing it yeah so
little don't don't solidify industry
solidify yourself first
then you need the Reps I'm not saying
you definitely need the Reps but I think
you have to you know solidify yourself
on who you are and understand who you
are and then do the Reps your your
growth will be times 10.
yeah I think a lot of us are like just
like almost spraying and praying it's
like people posting crowd work Clips
hoping it goes viral or oh let me do a
skit about uh making coffee and maybe
that'll go viral or like I feel like a
lot of us are just we're just like
posting and we're like all right I hope
this is the one type deal there's no
real thought or strategy Beyond I have
to post today because everyone else is
so maybe this is the post that makes me
go viral
yeah I mean like like either one of you
your girl Yoshi or whatever like what
you know are there any funny moments you
know you're talking about I mean hell
you had a bit right there about trying
to stay in comedy because yeah your girl
you know what I mean like yeah you know
do reels on that conversation
oh I like that yeah I mean you know what
I'm saying they like people like the
real [__]
yeah yeah I like that I mean I think
it's so it's so funny that you're
bringing this up because I was as you
were asking Joel about his micro moments
I'm thinking through my own like micro
moments of just like what I do and you
know I'm a I'm a stay-at-home dad I uh
I've got kids I take my kids I gotta get
them dressed I'm cleaning I'm spending a
little bit of time writing I'm doing a
little bit of work on producing shows
and then working on the comedy I'll I'll
try to make a real video like I'm doing
all the things and I'm like but the
thing that like I would say are you
trying to find moments within those
micro moments that you would say are
that's where your comedy is found or is
that's where your identity is in terms
of who your audience is
well I think it's both you know it's
like what's in you like when you're home
keeping the kids what's going through
your head
I don't want to be here okay exactly
[Laughter]
exactly home of the damn kids again [__]
you know what I'm saying like do do
something on that you know I mean
because comedians Minds will tell you
what you need to say
yeah because a good comedian turns a
thought process boom boom boom boom and
if you're in this space already your
mind your mind is going so fast just
pull those thought processes out of your
head and I think a lot of comedians cut
off their nose to spot their face
because they're afraid to pull the [__]
out of their head
yeah I see that yeah yeah I'm not afraid
I talk I do talk about some of this
stuff on stage but as I'm looking at
like even me and Joel just did a show
this past weekend together that was
super fun show and I'm thinking of the
audience and like that was so my
audience because I completely understood
everything that they were going through
in terms of who they are because they
were it was like a Suburban crowd
country white people is what it was John
it was a very nice country club and it
was rich white people
Yoshi's gonna sugarcoat it it was it was
a bunch of one percenters that's who it
was and I walked in I was like my people
[Laughter]
start talking [__] about that what the
hell am I doing here for sure for sure
okay you know and that yeah and you know
they're going to relate to that you
relate to it
you know yeah that's so something is
real
absolutely so when you sort of when you
find yourself what do you think the next
step is after finding yourself and sort
of you know sort of what did you do with
Southern Mama after you were like okay
this is the demographic this is the
people that we know we want to go after
what was sort of your next steps to sort
of take it next level and what is his
identity like what would you pinpoint is
like oh this is his identity and then
yeah expandable well he you know he's a
guy that has a female Tendencies you
know he he emulated his mother
know basically emulate his mother which
is a hard Southern woman
you know but he's a dude I mean but that
was his life he grew up gay suppressed
and you know and uh Alabama town and and
that was who he was that was his
experiences you know and I I think that
someone because of his oppression I
think he
digested everything that was said to him
as a kid because there's a lot of [__]
going through his head at the time and
didn't know if it was right to be gay
not to be gay
you know but you know if you have if you
have if you feel if if someone's gay or
whatever and you feel that you you feel
these female tendencies
he wasn't scared to put that out to the
world
so if like you know if you took Joe if
you did 10 videos of a conversation 10
reels of a conversation with your
parents about why you haven't had kids
yet
you know and you put that out to the
world you you should put that social
media out there
and by law of attraction
there's a there's a certain tone that
you're putting out
and people are attracted to tone it's
just like your friends that you hang out
with have a very similar tone
so if you put that content out to the
world and you stay in that vein of
content
and step and repeat step and repeat step
and repeat you start to bring in data
on who you're
fan base is right and and as that data
comes in because I'm writing a book on
how to find a perfect audience finding a
perfect audience and
you bring that you know you start
bringing that data in and then let's say
you get a big enough number of people
where you say all right I want I want to
look at the top 30 demographic and I'm
going to cater continue to cater to that
because whatever that tone is or that
top 20 30 percent then everything around
it will just be exponential
if that makes sense all right and the
other thing I saw too in Industry once
you establish your tone you have to you
need to stay in that vein and just just
that's where you gotta work over and
over and over and over and over and and
step and repeat and and one thing that I
realize too
industry had a standard way of marketing
Acts
and people one thing that they don't
look at is tools in the toolbox
so if you take one act that has a 50
percent
male fan base 50 female fan base then
you have another act with has a 90
female
10 male fan base
they use the same formula to Market
those acts and they may be the same
level of talent
but what you have to understand about
the that data once you understand what
you're tone in and tone is and who your
fan base is
I know that this guy's very talented I
know this guy's very talented but I know
that this 90 female fan-based person at
a 25 to 30 year old female is the most
reactionary and biggest buyer online
so when I put out content I know they're
going to respond quicker
because of that makeup
the males dilutes that response time
because they wait to buy [__] they wait
to respond
you know so you gotta kind of cater
you know your direction and and and
based on how you want to Market yourself
based on the tools in the toolbox which
are your demographics on who your law of
attraction is that is established by the
tone of your narrative
so you have several comedians on your
roster is that what you do with each of
them
is you kind of figure out their identity
in their tone and then start to build
like a consistent content marketing
strategy around that absolutely 100
percent
I mean we we you know I've trimmed down
a lot you know I'm trying to focus on
Darren I'm trying to put out Red
Squirrel
um
you know we're trying to be a little
more precise I don't want to do some
stuff you know from a human experience
and and try to teach some people some
stuff so we're kind of reeling back on
the amount of people we we work with now
but uh absolutely it's uh it's it's
figuring that out and you know and it
and for me it's a feel thing too
because like once I start working with
somebody
it takes me maybe 60 90 days before I
really understand them
so once you dig into this if you don't
have immediate media you understand your
tone you're getting the right data
um but if you don't have a you know that
quarterly success immediately don't
worry about it because if you establish
the foundation the right way
all you have to do is build on that
Foundation
just stay with it because a lot of
people I see too they try it and three
months they they short themselves
because they stop it when it takes 60 to
90 days to really hit stride
once you figure out what that vein is
just stay with it because the you know
when you build the foundation the right
way you'll have success
and I say Foundation that's that's the
people that are attracted to your
narrative
what are those early signs of success
because it is like you'll Post 10 reels
and they all get 10 views each and
you're like oh maybe I should try
something else now instead of seeing it
all the way through how do you know when
you're on the right track
like I said I think it's those real life
moments don't try to don't over produce
don't overthink it don't think there's a
perfect you know there's never a perfect
way to do it it's just get it get the
content out there
just do it just hey you feeling it
you're having a conversation with your
girl and it's funny you got some crazy
[__] going in that film and get it out
there you know you don't have to prepare
for the Oscars
you know and and and you know and I
realized that and I realized that in
television
you know a lot of this a lot of this
stuff I realize too is with social media
the casting call is already done for you
if you understand it
and if you think about Hollywood you
know 10 people in a room are going to
pick who the star is
you know and they don't even understand
the sensibilities of the star I mean
that's an old model
so think about how many people they
missed
because the 10 people they the 10 people
in the room didn't relate to that Talent
let the people decide
let the masses decide who you are not
the 10 people in the room don't worry
about industry the people will tell you
who who you are and who who your fans
are
yeah I'm starting to see a theme here uh
and the theme is
that's the industry
I mean you know by the by default
I mean you can't
you know you're talking 15 20 years ago
when five minutes on Johnny Carson or
whatever made you a superstar yeah and
today and today people are on there 10
times and can't sell three tickets
you know so
to that to the industry's default is
that I'm not saying screw industry you
just got to understand the changes and
and how do you adapt to that and I think
pattern patterns of business you know if
you've got guys created a pattern of
business
and they're making money they want to
stay in that same pattern of business so
that in a way they have blinders on on
what's changing around them
for sure but now
but but when you know we started with
like I said I I sold I rented the venue
I sold my own tickets I marketed the
show
I did everything myself and people told
me you know like you're not supposed to
do that but I was like why not
you know I would go to the clubs I would
go to the clubs and sell my own tickets
and pay the club
[Music]
yeah I mean and then and then Ralphie
May and all a bunch of Acts started
copying that you know and I we were the
first and the other thing is
understanding
the other thing is like you can't have a
lot of like in your content
you know I started the radio edits
I thought about the radio edits back in
the back way back in the day how it's
like everybody's got add
like you got to keep their attention so
I was the one that started that whole
Trend and everybody jumped on the radio
edits you know hit hit hit hit
so because you got to hit them get on
the first 10 seconds of perception just
boom
you know get it's almost like that click
bait video up front like whatever video
you do
find the the climax or whatever it is
take that three second piece put it at
the front of the video
and then it's bit bit bit you know
because that three second piece climax
will make them watch the video from
front to end I mean that's that's 20
right there
put the click bait up front
that's what you mean by radio edit is
like having that like teaser or that
hook at the beginning of the well the
radio no the radio well the radio you
got to have the teaser but the radio
edits were like you know line line there
was no transitions at all I took out all
the transitions because you lose when
you find content especially on social
media that have transitions you lose 20
30 percent of your audience just on that
alone
oh how it's like the quick cut of like
yeah one line the next line the next
line there's no like almost Breathing
Room in there yeah yeah it's almost set
up punchline tag tag tag tag yeah until
you hit a crescendo yes to keep their
attention because most people have ADD
ICT you know so you're you're appealing
to the add world
and just just think if you made a lot of
content that didn't have those punches
quick enough or you didn't have the the
climax up front for the click bait you
might have had great content but it
didn't do well because you didn't have
the right edit
hmm
there's that's another Factor you know
what I mean
it doesn't have to be pretty just do it
get it out there
and and you know if you if you shoot a
wide net
don't overthink it you will perfect your
con the the the fan base will tell you
how to perfect your content along the
way because you're gonna you're gonna
start to understand how these people are
responding
does that make sense would you start
with like quick short form videos and
like what platform would you prioritize
like because we're like I gotta post
everywhere so I end up posting nowhere
type deal I would get on I would get on
Facebook reels yeah men or less right
now big opportunity right now put the
click bait put your funniest moment at
three seconds at the top then Quick Cuts
and just start getting it out there
because the Facebook reels are going to
give you a lot of reach even and even
even YouTube
is is good you know and then Tick Tock
has this Tick Tock came to us about this
big Live program
uh I gotta see how that pans out and try
to understand that but you know lives
are good go live every day
you know I mean just just grind it out I
mean you're you're Pro you're Pro if you
did that with social
if you put the effort into your content
like you would your live shows
your progression will be faster
and you spend less you'll spend less
money traveling and shot
what advice would you have to like
overcome that fear or that
self-doubt or like I mean I've created
content and then like not posted it I've
been like all right I'm gonna do it and
I have it open on the app and then I end
up like not posting it like I I run I'll
run into that kind of resistance as well
like I said you just gotta do it who
gives a [__] yeah
I'm just saying like who gives a [__]
nobody it's not like you know nobody
yeah it's like you're not you're Jerry
Seinfeld yeah who gives a [__] just put
it out there like I said the the people
will tell you what you need to do
you just gotta be real get it out there
don't hesitate it doesn't have to be
perfect
you know just understand a few
principles
and just go
I mean does do I say I mean I talk you
know I talk about this stuff
and people look at me sometimes like
what the hell you know it's I guess my
narrative is really really different huh
compared to what y'all hear in the
business
you know I don't know if it's different
but you're definitely you're definitely
talking about things that most people in
the industry are not talking about right
because what you haven't said right is
that like focus on the five minutes
focus on the 10 minutes focus on the 15
the 20 like build your thing you've
mentioned it but that's what we're
hearing in the industry right like the
industry is all about like you got to
get that comedy right you got to get
those things right but what I'm hearing
and I think where the difference and
probably why you strung a chord in the
industry is that not you know I know we
keep using the word reverse engineer but
you're changing the mold by which people
are becoming successful with social and
you're changing the mode by which uh
artists and comedians are actually
getting their names out there and I
think it's so different than what people
are used to but you are hitting on us on
a narrative where this is the actual
Norm now people are getting bigger
through social media than they are
through the element of oh he had five
minutes and then we saw him here and now
he's here and now we've put him at this
pedestal area and now he's you know
opening for Jerry Seinfeld right like
the game itself is completely changing
and I think we're not hearing a lot of
people like you talk about that game
changing
well if you if you understand all these
factors I've been discussing right
you'll have enough material to carve out
whatever time you need for sure
you know yeah it's it's
already there you're just looking in the
wrong places
[Laughter]
that's a good point you know what I mean
I mean I mean I if you look at the
landscape I mean even to this day we've
been running strong for seven years
and and
I'm the only guy that
independently competes with
you know Live Nation you know AEG Global
you know the only promoter I I promote
all my shows I do all my shows myself at
a very high level I mean we're doing
thousand to two thousand Cedars this
year
uh I'm the only guy in the business
doing that
you know
um and the only promoter I do use you
know to help with shows is Outback
presents and Brian Dorfman you know
um because we have a good relationship
and he was actually Brian Dorfman was
the guy who let me in the door because
when we first started
I had I had nine shows
sold out in Nashville
and the venue that we were at didn't
want to do it so we moved nine sold out
shows
two Zanies
and then that's where it all began so we
spent like you know
10 days at Zanies starting out but
Brian's the one that let me in the game
yeah he owns Zanies right yeah yeah
yeah so I think I think the proof is in
the pudding and I think
what we did is not rocket science
and people just you know I think people
people know who we are they just don't
want to talk about it everybody knows
who we are they don't want to mention
they don't want to give us accolades or
anything but if they did
if they came and said hey let's figure
out this together
I think you're going to find more
success within the industry
because it's already been proven
does that make sense
yeah that makes sense I feel like me and
Joel's mine are like being blown right
now we're just like
my my brain is One Direction my brain is
going right now is that like I've had
moments on this podcast before and I'm
sure listeners have as well of like
oh
I'm learning about how this social media
comedian built a following it's my time
now now I'm gonna go and do it and
commit to it and then I I haven't and I
feel like a lot of people have done the
same thing so my brain is like well how
what can I do that's gonna be different
this time type deal after hearing this
and learning and all right picking up on
micro moments my life and working on
posting and not caring and trying to
find my identity and letting the
audience that does react kind of
help me steer the content in a way
that'll build a bigger following what
can I do to actually make this stick and
actually follow through you know
well I think you need to like looking at
you Joe like you need to go out in the
woods and do ayahuasca
and get rid of all your fear
get rid of the fear your fear the fear
is the only thing it's I like I I can
say look at both you guys your fear is
the only thing that's hindering you
get rid of the fear if you had no fear
you might be both of you might be two of
the biggest comedians in the country
but fear is the only limitation you have
that's all it is
don't there's no reason to be scared of
the industry what are you going to die
scared and never do nothing
to say
I mean that's basically what it is I see
more people that are fearful
of their selves why
go do Ayahuasca something do something
crack crack that you know crack it crack
in obviously you you know you're you
know you gotta a good podcast here both
of you look you have great personalities
you know I think is there anything that
you can do to break through that fear
um and you do this process that I told
you on this podcast
you will be more successful I guarantee
that hey honey me and Joe gonna get
messed up next week
we found the plug on Ayahuasca we're
gonna go in the woods honey
hahaha right through
through hell could you imagine Joel the
the conservative looking redheaded guy
with the youth pastor Alaska
the youth Minister you should do a youth
Minister series
[Laughter]
you know
seriously the youth Minister that would
be hey I think you have a youth youth
Minister tone you should do something
funny on that like the damn uh
uh what is it called what's his name
Andrew bride or Danny McBride does those
uh the show about the preachers oh yeah
righteous gemstones yeah I guarantee you
like church crowd with you Joe you do a
youth Minister you blow up the church
crowd
so what um what kind of skits could I do
like is it like a youth Minister that
gives bad advice or a youth Minister
like tries to be cool or that's not I
don't know did you go to church
I do on YouTube
so that's a start what'd you do when you
on it what'd you do when a kid you go to
church as a kid
I did yeah yeah yeah yeah
once I look at you for a minute I can
tell your life yeah yeah I mean think
about all that kind of [__] uh-huh you
know like the
the simpleness the simpleness on the
front but the craziness behind the lens
right it's like yeah the church I went
to Growing Up we met in like a high
school so it wasn't like you know it was
it was it was hit or miss church
so maybe that's the kind of Youth
Minister I am that meets
at like a school or something I don't
know uh
you know what I mean
I mean that's just funny
yeah
like that's that could be you know
that's really I think that's relatable
to your life
it is yeah I just don't now like it's
like okay there's a there's a youth
Minister tone now it's like what now
like skits like now it's just like you
said not overthinking it it's just doing
a few like yeah rants or silly things
yeah like what you know what kind of
conversations do you and your wife have
about you know about
you know do you and your wife have very
plain conversations and you're thinking
about you're having a plane your voice
is saying a plain conversation but your
head saying what the [__] going on
my mind's telling me no
you know that that that's very relatable
stuff universally
but I could see that from him I don't
know I don't know why
this is what I read youth minister is
interesting people in the comments like
Elder Joel as well
Elder dog
I like gardening as well so I I was
trying to do gardening content but maybe
it's Church content
but what but but how did you try to over
produce What Fear did you have to over
produce the gardening content
I just don't
just don't committed like I've posted
like three and then I'll be like oh it
didn't go viral never mind and then like
I just won't post again or whatnot like
I that's basically I just don't see it
all the way through
yeah what or what uh
what platforms have y'all been doing
stuff on
Facebook I've been posting the Facebook
reels and Instagram primarily
and you do a video a day
I have been lately video a day I know
that for sure
do a video a day
do a video day one video a day the three
seconds at the front radio edit
something's relatable get rid of the
fear
you know and I know that's hard tough to
do is get rid of the fear but uh you
know
that's what you have to do
you know
because obviously both of you you know
how many episodes you've done here
you're doing you know you got 200
something 300 episodes or whatever here
yeah I mean that's solid that's solid
just in itself
so there's there's a foundation there
yeah we could do more to promote this
show for sure but you know yeah how
would you Market a podcast how would you
Market our podcast to make us famous on
here maybe
um
the sauce yet
to really put a narrative out there for
the podcast that you know I've done
about 90 95 episodes of mine and it's
it's growing it's growing
um
I just uh I don't know yet on the it's I
don't know I'm trying to figure that
piece out gotcha when you are like
thinking about uh the people and the
talent that is like on your roster
I guess obviously Southern mama was you
know huge success story what other
elements are you looking for when you
bring on Talent like what it what's the
factors that these people have or that
like your talent roster has that you're
like okay this is something that we can
work with
people who are depressed as hell
yeah
[Laughter]
everyone in the live stream is like all
right got you right here John we're next
I mean I don't know it's kind of a it's
kind of a feel it's kind of a feel about
what it's kind of a feel about what I I
don't know it's a feel you know
I don't think I look at I think I just
got to see the person right
see a video or whatever I mean the video
I saw Darren was a video of him at trade
day
um and at the time A buddy of mine
um who's a big producer who used to do
all the show he's had all the number one
shows on TLC back in the days done I
don't know how how many hours of
Television he did a development deal
with the liberal redneck and then I saw
this video of Darren because I I was
about to partner with Chris Case who's a
big showrunner in LA
and I went to people in comedy they're
like he doesn't need a manager he needs
five years development and I said screw
it I said we'll just sign him and do
business and I just when I saw that
video as somebody I just somebody missed
him you were just you know it was just
real you know it was just real life
stuff
you know and I think you got to step
outside of
over produced industry business thought
process to step outside and be real I'm
just telling you film
just do a video do a video of you
getting out of bed at from eight to ten
do a video from 10 to 12 do a video from
12 to two of just normal [__]
you know I'm sure there's stuff you're
not both of you aren't telling me that
you say that could be funny in your
daily lives
you know I just finished putting
together this cleaning my garage for the
last like three days and the mental
gymnastics that I've been doing about
putting not about cleaning this garage I
haven't cleaned it in four years never
cleaned it and then all of a sudden this
weekend I was like I gotta get I gotta
clean this garage out and just the stuff
that I'm going through and this is like
Dad moment like my kids are like can we
play I'm like no I need to clean this
garage out like I'm neglecting my
fatherhood duties so I can clean this
garage yeah
yeah you got two or three reels just out
of that experience yeah the links you go
to to avoid your family
yeah you will literally do chores to
avoid your family
absolutely
yeah I mean yeah when do you want to be
away from your girl
when does your girl get on your nerves
yeah
I mean you know
you know relationships are very there's
a lot in relationships ton of stuff in
relationships because it's like
you want to walk out the door one minute
and then you want to you know love them
the next minute you know it's a
love-hate relationship you know
yeah dude talk about that [__]
everybody can relate to a relationship
um
I mean I do these little reels with my
daughter
about the stuff you know like I was
teasing her about she's gonna have to
pay rent at 18 when she turns 18.
yeah you know stuff like that you know
uh why you know one of y'all kids
communicate on Snapchat
you know this is not a lifestyle this is
not real you know just real that's a
real that's a real thing you know and
like those videos when my daughter got
like two three million
views each we've done several of them
you know but I I did them just to try to
bring awareness to things that were
affecting kids
yeah you know and social media
well as as we land This Plane here
um do you have any closing advice for us
John or big takeaways for to help us go
forth and actually do instead of
continuing to listen to other people's
advice
yeah stay out of the comments
um you know stay out of the comments
don't have if you build your foundation
the right way
you know stay out of the comments don't
have any knee-jerk reactions because the
other thing is emotions you know if
if you took if you understood the Earth
and you took ten bloodlines
and put them on the earth and they all
had different traits and you take
emotions out of that
you can determine what those Bloodlines
would do
but when you add the emotion to it
that's the creativity that's the
Juggernaut of the universe
so you know when you get emotional with
with comments or a perspective of
somebody else you know don't don't
listen to somebody else listen to
yourself
you know listen to yourself listen to
your own perspective
don't make need your don't make a
knee-jerk reaction knee-jerk reaction or
knee-jerk decision
that is an opinion about you because
only you know yourself more than anybody
else
um
well where could people because I
actually see Mary in the live chat just
said she messaged you on LinkedIn so
like people that listen to this and
found inspiration where
where can they reach out to you where
can they keep up with you I know you
have a podcast like where
yeah I mean the unimpressed podcast John
Edmonds Cosmos unimpressed podcast I try
to talk to intellects on there I've had
uh Hannah Ali uh Muhammad Ali's daughter
we talked about Muhammad Ali's life
um we had
um uh was the name Ali Loeb who wrote
the report he's the head of astronomy at
Harvard
uh you know I like to talk to a lot of
intellects you can check me out on
LinkedIn is is an easy messaging system
uh or just Google John Edmonds cosma
reach out and I'll hit you back
beautiful
all right this is it John we're doing it
this time
yeah first of all starting with the
ayahuascas I like that idea yeah yeah
yeah we'll make a road trip up there
John we need the plug
y'all come to Charleston come to
Charleston maybe y'all can come I'm
gonna be doing some shows uh some
smaller shows locally if you want to
come do some shows here in Charleston at
the Wonder
come on down we'll put you on the card
we'd love to yeah let's keep in touch
about that and get some dates going for
sure yeah because I think both of your
characters you just like I said I think
the biggest thing is fear
I keep reiterating I think the biggest
thing I feel I feel like you're hitting
my soul John you're just like you're
just beautiful I'm afraid you're right
right I think my my therapist said the
same thing so
we'll send our co-pay to John John
Edmonds Cosmo
which we said right this time cool man
well beautiful well thank you for your
time John thank you for everyone
listening join our email list to keep up
to date on future live streams and to
get extra content over there and we will
see y'all next week Hopper at the verse
love you appreciate y'all bye